obviously PAX Prime is a lot about games
not just video games tabletop games card
games all the kind of games your little
brain can think of but it's also about
the people who are here the events the
panels just the whole creative strata
that comes down the line when people
come together to celebrate the stuff
they love so if that in mind I'd like to
introduce my two guests to my right here
Mikey Newman and Chris Straub gentlemen
thank you for joining me
no problem pleasure I almost did not
make it here on time you are you're here
with plenty of time to spare but you
were running from the gearbox panel
yeah with main theater panel down on
it's like second in university or so so
what is it what is a gearbox pin so
you're a writer for gearbox yeah for it
and and more you know I technically my
team I title is chief creative champion
she's search ampion which means not a
lot no shorten it at all you still like
a try see it's come up you try to come
up yeah you go three C or C cubes wait
were you at where do you want to okay C
cubed so yeah we did we did the gearbox
panel and that was super fun Randy
Pitchford did the ice bucket challenge
on stage oh wow
which you know maybe could be worn out
welcome a little bit though it's great
cause we're making a lot of money doing
it
he actually laid down on his back in a
kiddie pool oh wow full and they they
dumped it super slow from speed all the
way up and he I've never seen him freak
out so physically before he was like it
was it was actually kind of terrifying
we're like are you okay do you need do
you need a blanket do we need a towel we
just covered him in town they'd have to
have medics on staff for that type of
thing we did not that was actually
probably the one thing we done
incredibly irresponsible Randy Pitchford
come on man but for a good cause it was
a great guy great cause so you've been
doing that you were doing some some
gearbox stuff here but you also
delivered two packs keynote right and it
talked to me like keynotes differ widely
from packs to
axé the sort of the format changes the
speaker's change what was your situation
like what you want to deliver well I
cuz Robert ku was the one that asked me
originally and he sent me an email and
he's like hey do you want a keynote a
pax and I said of course right I mean
that's awesome yeah and I had really
thought about was gonna say at that time
and he's like well which one you want to
do and I thought it was gonna be packed
south because I'm from Texas anyway nope
I was just like well pax burns my
favorite he said lock it in so yeah for
like six months I guess I've been
thinking about it and I I'm sure we've
all noticed that over the last month two
months it's it's gotten to a riled up
situation out there in our industry
that's and I wanted to I wanted to go on
stage and kind of try to start bringing
this back together a call for sanity and
the the main point was just about
spreading joy so I went well Hannity joy
those are like on my top list they do go
together the Venn diagram we have her
lap yeah
so the gaming sort of connection for you
Mikey
is through gearbox is through
Borderlands actually before we talk to
you in a second Chris but we have to
roll this interview that I dug up the
first time you and I met I was telling
them about this in 2009 Aaron's was just
first announced at e3 we're gonna get
our interview up here and take a look at
us five years ago this is probably say
maybe my second III interviewing and
yeah there it is I'm Matt's like Matt
Damon this was a really fun inner look
at those glasses what do I think of from
space what am i doing man Google glass
without any of the electronics in it
it's just yeah he's fashion-forward you
know today it's Google ask glasses
that's a big my favorite thing to come
out of that was a user comment that said
we looked like schooldays friends I
guess is cool that's actually really
funny considering part of my keynote was
actually just about this story from
fifth grade oh really I feel like we
brought it up I
can't believe you dug that up that's
awesome oh my god yeah no I was like
Borderlands really excited recess come
play it right I got my crackers got my
juice I'm ready to go so you guys
collaborate also outside of the gearbox
software realm and that's on your
website or I mean I guess you guys sort
of it's your brain so calm yeah I'm a
cartoonist I work out of the Penny
Arcade offices I've known them for a
long time mm-hmm I did the intro
animations for acquisitions incorporated
that stuff every year which was a huge
hit last night yeah a pleasure I
couldn't attend it's it's 4:00 we had a
panel we had our show opposite and
acquisitions incorporated for those who
don't know it's the Dungeons & Dragons
live the celebrity game yeah
very year so but you're a cartoonists
people can check out I mean I'm sure
people have seen this maybe you know
they pick ups too freaking okay Rankin
oh you're getting a little extra let's
give that manly a style under $50 we
stop now actually can we yeah give me
some of that they will do it don't don't
tempt them I saw it
hover so this thing's we going for a
little while now yeah yeah I bet a
chainsaw suit I've done since like 2008
but I've been at cartoonist since 2000
dimensionally professionally as a friend
as much as anybody as a professional do
you go to comic-con ever yeah I went to
San Diego comic-con for 10 years I have
thought was going but my first year was
this year yeah and it was just I had to
sad Charlie Brown's long night cloud
following me like you're like
hanging out on both I wish you're here a
lot of boat actions if your boats here
send you one of them is real big they
put planes on it yeah one of the larger
boats I've seen
yeah actually San Diego is a boat I did
not that's amazing
hashtag tweet us that hashtag San
Diego's the boat your chance to win a
dinner with Chris waters the hashtag
it's got to be true it's true that is
what brings all things into being these
days yeah but chainsaw suit you guys
have you've got the comic there but you
guys also do a podcast we do we have a
podcast on a YouTube channel the podcast
is chainsaw sitcom slash podcast we've
done as of last night 70 episodes so
it's not up yet how would you describe
the show Chris let's talk it's comedy
and it's it's well sponsored as well
yeah oh yeah we are our own sponsor
sponsor one of my favorite things about
this we throw to fake commercials
constantly yeah
what were the ones we did because we had
some for the panel that we made
literally in an hour no I did one for a
purell retribution it's no longer about
hand sanitization no it's about making
the germs themselves sick
oh really because we've lost the battle
yeah it's over for all we can do now is
strike at them from Arctic it's just
attrition over the point yeah and then
and then mine was it was for the long
john silver's fish plank enchilada the
long john silver's fish plank enchilada
which as we go because there's like we
can make fun of a product but we
actually just did this thing about how
the guy hated too much and he was
communicating through a Ouija board with
a fish plank enchilada on it to his
daughter because that's what you can
expect from chainsaw yeah we also have a
youtube channel slash chainsaw salute
original or do you do on the youtube
while we animate some of the commercials
you have to show you're doing a series
called movies with Mikey yes check that
out well received which it's pretty
straightforward there's movies there's
Mikey I if I if I met reactive I don't
know wait Chris please give this
ah it actually goes in line with your
keynote when you talk about positivity
and joy there's a lot of review stuff on
YouTube that's just like taking movies
apart and fie
all the negative stuff you love these
movies and you're having them and giving
a lot of information about why and part
of its like finding hidden gems a good
wanna start with weed The Last Action
Hero review if you can find that I would
think well I even I didn't remember it
being as baller as it was but the in the
last section here of you just to give
you a preview of what I do here I talk
about Schindler's List and the symbolism
in that movie and then I talk about the
symbolism in Last Action Hero oh wow and
what starts as a joke you realize no
it's actually deeper and more of an
exhibitionist action hero than it is in
Schindler's List heightened there's this
great movie very surface level it's like
oh she's got a red sweater I don't know
if I want to lead with that example it
sounds like a no yeah but you know you
get you get deep on cinematic theory how
is what's gonna take it yeah hashtag
9/11 was a boating accident
Oh Last Action Hero
I was actually pleased to hear you
extolling the virtues of a long kiss
good night yes oh my god well these are
two because we have Shane black wrote
this film and Shane black also wrote the
long kiss good night which I love I
think if Samuel Jackson's greatest film
rollerball is not his Samuel Jackson nor
is he in it he was like a key grip I
think but yeah it's it's it's a show
where I get a celebrate movies my my
next review is actually Waterworld and
that wasn't requested whoa oh yeah some
of its like can you accept the challenge
of the film and Waterworld I realized
something really crazy just to break you
up a little preview all of their
costumes are like if you look at Dennis
Hopper in the movie he plays this very
surface level villain but he has glasses
turned sideways to make the eyepatch for
his missing eye it's implied that those
are his glasses because he has trouble
seeing things like from a distance and I
was like so when you actually look at
all these characters like the guy with
the six-pack plastic rings for cokes and
stuff made in bet there's all these like
stories in their costumes yeah I'm gonna
reconstruct this entire
narrative of the movie that actually
exists under the not so awesome movie on
top I the upshot of all this and you've
also like written a few novels is that
you guys kawaii and are like this
incredible creative force like not just
in your professional lives but also your
personal lives obviously your great
friends and romantic lives yeah mansik
lives where you know psychosexual lives
the whole all levels all that all the
Jungian fragments
well I mean you you have broodhollow as
well which I would I would be remiss if
we didn't talk about a little bit that's
right it's a dude that's my most recent
webcomic effort I did a Kickstarter for
the first book last year it did very
well nice it's the short hand pitches
Tintin goes to Innsmouth Lovecraftian
but like at 19th okay that's also gone
with Tintin goes to Twin Peaks nothing a
little just a little maybe if you're a
younger person your own dismisses they
have to know what it is well ok sorry if
you don't know is that's what's right in
there oh I wouldn't show the new comics
though if they pull it up yeah it's kind
of spoilery that's ok no I should buy it
no all right
sorry no to figure this out with that
guy you've lost control this interview
of waters come on did I ever have it no
or you doing good for me oh yeah I mean
I'm excited to get out to the Indian
mega booth today oh yeah some games
there hopefully I've been doing doing
show stuff hosted a civilization panel
yesterday I am so have you played it yet
oh yeah
dang it I'm jealous if five is my
favorite game of all time I love it I
love it I love it love it be on I cannot
wait it's looking pretty cool alright
but I want to bring it back real quick
to try to hold on to the last vestiges
of control I have over the situation
before it just all spins out and well
we're gonna welcome the stage guest to
talk to them they'll have to both sit
there though I think
because I'm staying right here ya know
clearly it's the whole like the the
staggering amount of sort of creative
like art and expression that you guys
both that sort of output is inspiring to
me because you know I get to I get to do
some fun stuff here at GameSpot but like
you know I thought about like maybe like
writing a little book one time or maybe
like doing a youtube series but you know
I feel like a lot of people there's not
that that initiative that hustle that
that drive to sort of start creating the
thing that they are daydreaming about or
you guys it's nothing you do it because
you love it and then it doesn't matter
whether or not it succeeds or fails I
even if it failed you're still doing it
because you love still doing it yeah
just to attack is like in a
collaborative way sure yes I've done a
lot of side projects with with a few
different people and I remember when we
originally because we both lived in
Dallas for a long time and now you
didn't you went to LA and then Seattle
well I know I didn't know I'm in Dallas
at the time we didn't know each other at
all and you were coming because we were
doing a show at PAX they've like two and
a half years ago or whatever right um
you were coming to pick me up and I was
I was worried because I was I did or I
heard Chris was an a-hole like I've been
told that and I was like oh here we go
we got out of the car like down the
street to get sushi I mean it was like a
two minute drive and we're like hey you
wanna be best friends because it was
like it was crazy clattering yeah and
that person was wrong about me
no they weren't actually what I actually
am enable I'm just really good at baking
it's alright sorry I think we
consistently set a bar for each other
especially when it comes to comedy and
even even like the positivity in comedy
cuz that's always been our slant is like
people like Joe don't don't punch down
punch up and we're like what if we
didn't punch anyone what if we but what
if we also punched laterally what if we
also punched ourselves yeah yeah I mean
itself don't we I mean we punch some
brand like TGI Fridays and Guy Fieri you
know we don't feel as bad about taking
digs at Long John still
I mean that was similar they know that
fish plants will get diagon's a fish
blanket gelada they take the the beach
plank American cheese hush puppy batter
and they deep-fry it's the fish but it's
off menu real no it's not real okay I
wish it was
I don't we fish because we love I don't
know about fish places that's okay
there's time to divide me bro I think
calling laundry so fish places maybe a
little strong fish in that chain
somewhere the supply chain go back far
enough in folks fish at least right fish
fish fish your nine fish style so having
a creative sort of someone to bounce
stuff off of someone to collaborate with
is that a is that a sort of a way that's
been it's been obviously has been
gratifying for you guys do you think
that that's sort of a powerful way to
kind of give yourself a little bit more
energy do you get get energy from each
other like
dedicate like to claim that time during
your day I'm gonna take this one yeah
I'm a very funny person but I'm most of
the lowest possible energy person and
I'm kind of arised
I use this really silly metaphor to
describe this yesterday I'm gonna say it
yeah cheesy but accurate but cheesy if
you have two knives and you're trying to
use them separately eventually they'll
dull but if you take both knives and
constantly sharpen them off of each
other they're better nine and but the
knives grow to hate each other they
cannot stand each other there's just a
lot of yeah a lot of tension it develops
good tips knife sounds like that a great
point about knives moves out of the
state even though you know you hadn't
met yeah bummer crack it back I'm a big
fan of collaborative humor and I think
that I to go out by myself somewhere I
don't know if it would play as well like
I need somebody to play off well even at
the table because this is we have the
Chris drama Mikey human chainsaw salute
table out in band land if you're here
come see us yep come get an elimination
chainsaw suit print but it's so it's
salesman it's amazing of course but I'm
saying like when you're if you're alone
at a con at a table it's nowhere near as
fun as just sitting around your best
friend and signing stuff and it's like
wow this is amazing so
so yeah you can be a third Betsy no
listen listen it's a love seat for two
you know I'm happy to just be near you
know it's just it's just the right width
alright we were coming to the end of
this conversation situation yeah let's
do that let's do the rundown what do you
want what do you want some viewers to
see to do to to check out come on if
you're here come out see us in Van land
otherwise you can find us at chainsaw
sitcom subscribe to our podcast
yeah shape so salute original on YouTube
we're both very handsome
yeah look at us visually Borderlands the
pre-sequel coming out this October
please check that out yeah it's awesome
it's actually really awesome
it's pretty fun nice claptrap as the
viewers saw earlier I'm I'm fairly
certain I can say it's my favorite
Borderlands experience now added and not
it's it's it's added so much to it it's
it's rounded about I really enjoy my
stop is where is what you're really I'm
just saying you can but stop and shoot
acid at can I give it a shot today I'm
putting it I'm try to get yeah oh no I
yeah came off to play Borderlands Mikey
Newman Chris Rob thank you guys so much
for chatting talking packs over
obviously some time I'll go get a
chainsaw shoeprint mandolin please do